everyone
people joining in let's give them a few
more minutes before we start the
convocation
all right let's give them two more
minutes before we start
it's uh
801 ist
let's give them two more minutes to join
i can see people joining
so
i can see the panelist also joining in
so
let's give
all right
a finalist as well
all right let's get started then
all right
hello everyone um i would like to
welcome everyone present here to the
first online convocation ceremony for
the year 2021 hosted by simply learn in
association with the caltech ctme
i'm naveen srinivasan senior program
manager at simplylearn responsible for
learner success for ctme and other
technology programs at simplyla
first and foremost i would like to say a
big congratulations to everyone for what
you have achieved the last few months
this is when i remember my convocation
at b-school where i was nervous excited
for the future and at the same time i
had a huge sense of relief that all the
hard work and struggle was done and now
i just take a back seat just relax and
enjoy the moment
i'm pretty sure many of you here would
resonate to my thoughts today
today is indeed a celebration
a celebration to acknowledge your hard
work
your dedication your intent and your
grit in successfully completing the pg
program with caltech ctme and simply
learn
now let's take a step back and remind
ourselves about the journey that we have
been through
i believe the most difficult part for
any learner must be to sit through the
weekends for eight hours every weekend
week after week for seven to twelve
months
this is no joke right uh this can only
be achieved with sheer determination and
support from your uh truffle from your
family and friends around you
i would like to thank them on your
behalf for their continued support in
making your success story
and the road to success doesn't come
easy as well it comes with hundreds of
hours of learning through lgc classes
and online self-learning videos and
doing around 20 plus assessments and
projects taking up quizzes and then
finally implementing all your knowledge
in completing the capstone project
that's when you go and unlock your
certificate
it honestly requires a lot of commitment
and passion to achieve this and i would
like to take this moment to applaud and
appreciate each and every one for your
effort thank you so much
moving on
it's time for our guest speakers to
address the gathering
first i would like to take this
opportunity to introduce mr kashab dalal
a chief business officer and co-founder
during his time he has peer-headed
several initiatives and has been a major
driver in the road to success of
simplyland
being an iit iim allen kashar truly
believes in delivering world-class
products and has always been working
from getting to better to best
kashif is extremely passionate about
this program and has been a key factor
to success of this program at central
welcome kashyap and i would like to
you to speak few words to our graduates
today
hi thanks duveen it's a pleasure to be
here and thanks for a very generous
introduction
hi everyone a big congratulations to
everybody who's graduating from
these programs
i think as they say software is eating
the world right and
i think there is no better time to
graduate from such
you know privileged programs in the area
of technology cloud devops and full
stack so i think a huge congratulations
to all of you and i would really want to
you know reiterate the amount of
dedication and hard work that goes into
completing a comprehensive program of
this sort uh
congratulations for you know being there
through the last nine to 12 months and
reaching the stage where you are
graduating from one of the most
prestigious programs
from simplylearn and caltex atme
so
wish you all the best and i hope that
you know this becomes a key milestone in
you guys reinventing your career moving
forward and using the knowledge so that
you can achieve great things
thank you thank you so much
thank you thank you for all the kind
words
next i would like to introduce our guest
of honor today dr rick hefner he's the
program director at california institute
of technology
he's an extremely humble person to work
with and his achievements speak volumes
about what an accreditation he is
he is an alum of odd university and has
completed his phd in mechanical
engineering from ucla
dr hefner is extremely knowledgeable
across broad varieties of disciplines
related to software and systems
engineering and also process improvement
his insights and guidance has been
extremely valuable for the success of
this program dr hefner thank you for
being here today now i would request you
to speak few words to our graduates
thank you naveen and welcome to all of
our graduates um today and to my fellow
panelists here
thank you for your time
um
graduation is a very very special moment
at caltech and uh
even though we have to do this
graduation remote um
let me just say how proud we are of all
of you and the hard work and i would
echo the the comments of kashif and
nadine
in terms of the hard work that you put
in
um i want to recognize and thank um
the folks that kind of helped you get
here um all of your instructors both at
caltech and simply learn
all of the support staff that were there
a lot of people behind making this kind
of program a successful program and
my thanks go out to all of them
now let me
let me uh thank you and recognize all
the hard work that you've put in um
when we envisioned this program um and
started talking to simply learn about it
there has been a
bag from what they have designed
i mean maybe we should uh um
continue and then uh when rick comes
back online
uh
okay
sure
he seems to oh there he goes here he
comes you hear me now
yes yes
okay sorry
so i'm sorry did was any of that
uh heard or nothing you were at the uh
thanking staff and and the work behind
uh the program
okay um so i'm not sure exactly what
happened but let's uh let's continue on
um and just uh i just want to again
congratulate the graduates on the on
their achievements
this is a very rigorous program you
wouldn't expect anything less of caltech
and so
we have
put together the program really to make
sure that you walked out of this program
with um all of the job skills that you
needed which
means we had to have very broad coverage
we had to have very deep coverage um so
significant amount of time and effort on
your part to complete
this kind of programs
um we recognize that that that's
appropriate um i think for this
we want the certificate to mean
something to you and to your employers i
think we
put together a program to do that
as naveen said though i would also ask
challenge you to do two things
number one recognize the other people
your family and friends that made
sacrifices to make this happen
i'm sure
this was not just your effort it was
other people's efforts to cover your
responsibilities or
to allow you the time and energy of the
costs to do these kind of programs so um
please take some time today and just
just recognize those people and thank
them for their support of your efforts
and then the second challenge i would
make to you is is take advantage of the
opportunity
you've gotten
an education one of the best programs in
the world
please leverage that use that to change
your life change your career path change
your career direction
advance in your career
it's a tremendous opportunity
education is a gift and i hope you will
use the gift that you receive
to further your life
with that congratulations to all the
graduates
thank you dr hefner for all the kind
words and insights this is nice hearing
from you
next we have our chief guest mr mark
morin chief marketing officer at simply
learn
mark has been a senior business
executive who's carrier spans managing
divisions of fortune 500 corporations
and he has been senior leadership roles
at startups that has cumulatively
generated around 1.5 billion in exit
value
he focuses on a mixed data of soft
skills to grow and mentor highly
functioning teams
being an mba from stanford university
mark's functional expertise lies in
marketing strategic and corporate
planning
with his deep experience as a marketing
leader he brings a delicate balance of
aligning and the needs of users as well
as the organization
thank you mark for being here with us
today now the graduates would love to
hear from you
thanks naveen
hi everyone i'm i'm really very honored
to be part of the celebration of your
achievements
um there's no avoiding the fact that you
are the pandemic class lets us all hope
that you uh that there aren't very more
of them after you
i'm at a time when many people have been
overwhelmed by the global situation and
their specific circumstances
you all have chosen to take back control
of your lives and invest your time and
efforts in your future
and i just think that is uh unbelievably
impressive
and you you really should be proud of it
you are a very uh diverse and
accomplished group of folks
across these three pg programs you've
acquired
what really are the most some of the
most in demand skills in the world
depending on who you are and where you
take your future that might be a cloud
architect that might be a full stack
developer might be a devops
software developer it could be many
permutations of the above
or a number of alternatives your skill
sets are very broadly applicable
and i'm sure that there are some among
amongst you that someday in the future
may take
all this knowledge and cumulative skills
and start companies of your own
i also echo what rick said and that
uh you know i wish for you not only
um a great career success but to think
about what kind of impact you can have
uh with your skills
um both within your companies and within
society
at large
um
uh some of you you know may take these
uh and not just do uh commercial
endeavors maybe you'll take an advanced
science and medicine
uh you know perhaps we'll get better
drug treatment for something like the
coronavirus thanks to some of the work
that you may do in the cloud or with
with programming
uh and you know some of you may
literally take cloud computing
into outer space that seems to be one of
the next frontiers so i you know i think
the the future is is really limitless
for you all and it's a very exciting
moment
um and as they say uh you know the fun
begins now
so uh well uh please do take uh take the
weekend and take some time to
uh you know revel in your success and
reaching this milestone
um you know now now uh now really it's
time to apply what you've learned
um
and uh i want to leave you with a couple
of quotes
uh from two wise men to think about as
you uh
uh enjoy and celebrate one is uh jeff
bezos
from jeff
what we need to do is always lean into
the future
when the world changes around you and
when it changes against you
what used to be a tailwind now
a headwind you have to lean into that
and figure out what to do because
complaining isn't a strategy
and you've all shown already that you
have that mindset
the second quote is from peter drucker
the best way to predict the future is to
create it
now
now what you're all in the midst of
doing not only creating your own future
but creating a future for your
organizations and society at large
with that i wish you all the best we
would love to keep in touch
uh please reach out to us and let us
know how you're advancing your careers
we also would love to keep you active in
our community
there are hundreds of learners who are
coming behind you
you can be mentors to them uh while
continuing continuing on your own
journey
i wish you all the best and thank you
again for choosing simply learn
and allowing us to be part of your
journey
have a great weekend and savor this all
it's a pleasure to be here thank you
thank you so much mark for the
inspiring and wonderful words i'm pretty
sure our graduates are
pumped up with what you have said
thank you so much mark
so today learners it's all about your
achievements and what the future holds
for you uh before we get there uh before
we get to the next segment we have few
uh of our
graduates fellow graduates who would
want to share their learning experience
with us there are few peers who have
volunteered to share their learning
journey with us so i would like to call
upon
one each of them one by one
so we'll start with
namrata poonam from uh post graduate
program in cloud computing
panelists could unmute
amrita the host can unmute mumbaita
and hear a speak
please let us know otherwise
can you
are we audible
right
can you hear us
okay
so
we will circle back
okay we'll circle back
robbie
robbie wants to talk all right sure sure
robbie
want you can you mute robbie
sure i'm on it
yeah
they are facing problem in unmuting
themselves
give us
time so that we have everyone speak
yeah robbie i unmuted you
one
uh i also put on the camera but i think
that you can't see me right because it
was a request by
simply learn
a lady she asked me to
make me visible but not sure quite the
same issue anyway never mind
so
um
sorry for the quid pro quo
my name is roberta but
everybody calls me robbie so i like it
it's shorter
so
okay my experience guy hi everyone um
thank you caltech and simply run for
this opportunity and
congratulations to all of you for
completing this postgraduate course
for some of you like me the last year
has been full of challenges and
sacrifices
not only of our rest time but also
financially
one year ago we decided to embark in
this journey to expand our skills and to
stay relevant in it
well today we did it
i landed with caltech postgraduate
course in simply learn after several
research online
i was looking for a postgraduate online
course with an interesting program
possibly offered by a well-known
university and i got caltech
i bumped into simply learn and i was
happy to find
all what i was looking for
i want to speak about my experience with
them the enrollment process was smooth
and pleasant simply learn team guided me
in all the steps
afterward each time when i had an issue
the support team was always promptly to
assist me so thank you
i can't say that my experience was
always totally positive
but i would definitely repeat this
journey with simply learn definitely
this program offered me
uh this program that you offered is what
the current market is looking for
and this course gave me the solid
foundation to proceed with this
specialization
i really wish you all the best
and to have a strong career in cloud
stay relevant stay hungry
thank you everyone thank you
thank you robbie for all the kind words
it was really inspiring to hear from you
thank you so much so namrata can you
can you speak now
is it
are you able to speak now or
do you want it a bit later
all right i think she's uh
facing some
uh challenge i guess i think you have to
accept
permatex
you'll see a pop-up in your screen which
says
you want to be unmuted so you have to
accept the permit and you will be
it
under
okay let's let's move on so
next we have uh sonal nikam from pg
devops
so
panelist can you
please mute
odin
we will get back to you number one we'll
again do that you
will definitely
love to
please
i hope everyone is doing well and
staying safe
i did my post graduation
and since last five years i am included
technology i have last year i've joined
ibm and worked as an organization
even after having a very good experience
in devops
i always wanted to have you know some
specialization and recipe
so as remote is one of the emerging
field and domain that we all know so i
always wanted to have something you know
it's like a cherry on the cake if i have
some a proper degree in it or something
like that and we all know as our
education system doesn't offers us all
the latest things that comes into the
park
so
i mean i was really lacking this thing i
really
devops pg programs online and i came
across many universities that were
offering it
i actually considered mit first but then
i came across simply learn the courses
and the survivors that they offer
that
from a ci cd to from orchestration to
containerization from a configuration
management tool to you know
infrastructure provisioning
so everything from the base to the top
so that is the reason i thought you know
i should go ahead with that
because this will really help me
grow and make my base more stronger
so after that again after enrolling
yourself it is not an easy thing because
again we are from a working class so
it's very difficult for us to you know
balance and be able to
pursue this degree
a lot of things but still the simply
learned platform and the customer
support
they were really really helpful i have
[Music]
or if there is something that you know i
was stuck at any point so the customer
support team really helped me in many
ways so
i mean even as mark said at this time
it's pandemic and the situation was very
new for us everything is online
everything is culture so again i was
very skeptical what if i enroll myself
and then i have to chase people here
or if i am facing any difficulties right
but thankfully i i mean the team was
very helpful and because of them i was
able to you know without their help i
think it would have been a little
difficult for me but with their help and
support i was able to see it in a more
smoother way thanks to the simple long
and the thing that i achieved at the end
of this course and it really helped me
in many ways to be honest i mean i was
already working into devops
as we all know that devops is a kind of
appeal which is very dynamic you learn
one thing and you start getting a good
hold about it and the new technology
comes into your market and then you have
to leave this one and you have to start
with the new you have to be very
flexible so
many times
that it's very difficult for us to you
know have that basic understanding how
things are working in back end we know
that how it is working in front end and
it is as it is working for us so it is
fine for us this is how i mean most of
the people
think in that way but because of this
course
really helped me to understand how
things are working
and how you know
i had more clarity about things my base
and everything become more strong and
concrete
so this course gave me a lot of
opportunity to understand things at a
very granular level and i
am really thankful about this thing
thank you for the opportunity
thank you thank you so much sonal that
was really good to hear it it invites us
to work more harder and give you a
better learning experience thank you so
much for that
so next uh we will have uh janakiram
mecca from pg devops
uh host can
mute
get
out of me
can you
hear us speak you are muted you can
speak
hello
yes we are able to hear you yeah um
thank you so much um i would like to
thank caltech and simply learn uh
for giving me uh these wonderful
opportunities to speak in front of you
guys
um i'm actually uh
did a pg program on devops
and the experience is
i mean i would say i would divide in two
parts the first half and the second half
the first half is not so uh exciting um
with the support and all but the
gradually the support really really
improved
and the ending was really good i mean
for me um
as working and
attending classes and weekends saturday
and sunday with two kids it it's
damn damn difficult to you know
concentrate and you know finish the
course
within the time and
prior to this i i do not have any
experience on devops and i was actually
um
wanted to do a
degree on cyber security in ucla and it
was almost i finalized and then later i
decided that i should go for devops and
because my organization is leaning
towards devops they are implementing so
many things on devops so then i was
researching on on
in the internet and i got the caltech
and i did not even know that simply
learn was behind this but i the moment i
see the caltech is offering devops i
blindly opted and and then
started researching on it then i got to
know learn is is the
platform
where the caltech is is providing this
then i went ahead and contacted the
simply learn and the initial
conversation will simply learn is
excellent i would say the way they
received and
provided all the information it was
really really
good and i i was really um
motivated that this is a new gonna be
very exciting and you know it will
definitely help me in my uh
future in in my current or in in the
next jobs or whatever wherever i go
um
the
and the most important thing is the
course um the course
content crafted really good to cover all
the all the
aspects of devops i would say from scrum
to kubernetes docker
ansible
um
jenkins i mean it was i mean i i really
love to learn those things and
and the way it was crafted it was really
nice i i uh and the teaching staff was
really really nice on i would like to
mention um
the talkers by
solomon and kubernetes by nares
those those are really excited me to
learn more and
and go in depth in those things and it
is these courses are really helping me
right now in my current organization
and i i really thank simply learn
to come up with such a nice program and
collaborating with
caltech university
i would
i feel lucky to get
a time when you know i was wanted to do
some mastercals and i got this one
um and more more important thing the
the projects i mean course and projects
those are really challenging
and uh and those those looks like a real
time um projects uh
and definitely it will help
everybody who's gonna
make their career in devops
i i congratulate everybody who were part
of
my cohort uh pc divorce program and all
the best everyone thank you
thank you so much johnny graham it's
really nice to hear that uh you have put
all your learnings into work
and uh we hope uh we wish you all the
very best for the future
next we have
tirta haldar from
pg cloud computing
the host can
unmute uttar
be able to smooth
don't think he joined so
sure no issues so
next we have uh shermy gauche from uh
post graduation program in cloud
computing
can you check if uh
i can't see her also like she's also not
sure i guess no problem
um
we will have zulika zafi from pgfsd
zolika is present you can mute
uh she has also not joined uh i guess
namrata can uh is ready now
sure okay can we please mute
yeah
but as there is still a problem
there is still a problem i guess with
the like she was ready but uh i can
still not see her uh moving to the
balance
that's fine that's fine
so uh
can you check if um
doesn't if then
he want to share his thoughts with us
yes
i can see you
yes check out nothing you can speak now
yes loud and clear
great
check if we can switch on
video
okay
there you are yes
hey hi guys
um hi everybody um
so um
i'm a software developer uh put up in
brussels with around 15 years of
experience
uh i'm a student uh i was a student in
the pg program in devops
offered in collaboration with caltech
ctme and that word by simply learn
it gives me great pleasure to be talking
to all of you
um let me at the outset congratulate
everyone who is graduating today
kudos to everyone
uh needless to say this is a moment of
great joy and satisfaction uh after all
the time we spent you know on the course
all our
academic efforts have come to fruition
a special thanks to all our instructors
from across the globe
uh who taught us on the course on the
simply learn course
uh
um
you know they joined in from
various parts of the globe and each one
of them was amazing in their own way
they all
they all had their own different styles
of coaching
and
if you see it was a culminating
experience when you realized at the end
of the course
how the differences converged
and and and how beautifully the course
come comes out
at the end
um i would like to thank the simply
learn team for their labs and the
platform and the instant help with all
the issues
um i'd like to thank the caltech program
director rick hefner and other
instructors from the master classes of
ctme for designing such an excellent
industry oriented applied course
um i'm delighted to be a microscopic
part of such an extreme university like
caltech through this course
lastly uh it is to our loved ones that
i owe my deepest thanks you know having
supported us in always the nine months i
spent on this program it was not only
eight hours of live class every weekend
but also the times spent for the study
and the practices
that we had to sacrifice having not
spent with them
um it wasn't easy to manage all of this
amidst a full-time job family kids the
crisis etc
for some of you i'm sure it wasn't easy
to wake up for all those early classes
and it certainly wasn't easy if you have
a kid who is not happy that you're
sitting in front of your laptop on a
beacon
but the course showed me that if
something was easy it was probably
boarding
and
if i wasn't testing my limits by pushing
me with the schedule for classes having
a schedule attendance
and assignments i was probably
approaching it the wrong way
um we were not held by the hand uh by
the instructors we were not coddled by
the instructors we were thought
thoroughly
both using the live and using the
self-learning videos we learned the
concepts that i may have heard before
but wouldn't have had the cuts to dig
deep into
but research has showed that students in
study groups are happier and achieve
higher grades than those who do all
their work alone i cannot agree more on
that you know the cohort in which i was
was diverse with beginners to highly
experienced people
and learners from across the globe it
felt like a classroom atmosphere it felt
like back in college
i cannot remember an instance where we
asked the question and it was not
treated by the instructors
with whatever power the tool webex could
offer you know of course
discussions were enlightening
great that i have recordings of all such
discussions which i can go back to
whenever i want
it's a challenge for all of us now
take everything that we have learned
here into the real world and make the
best of it
while getting certified has its benefit
it shouldn't end there
practicing the concepts learned and
applying to real-time projects should be
the motive
complexity diversity and pace of change
will characterize the business
environment of the future
and we will necessarily have to compete
in that environment by embracing change
and with every change comes the need for
us to learn to adapt to that change
it's not going to be easy but i want to
want you all to continue to make
progress
progress with continuous learning
whether it be at work or just becoming a
better person in life
always continue to make progress with
learning
and simply learn is making our lives so
much easier with its our winning
learning platform for this
i strongly believe that excellent
coaching and the content that has been
provided to us here
we will be able to face the
ever-changing world of devops with
confidence
we are living in a time of far-reaching
changes you know in devops like kit offs
mlaps ai ops etc not only devops but you
know cloud uh
everything
post covered you know work from home is
is a force to reckon now by every
enterprise which gives that little scope
to do much more of such online programs
i'm happy to share with you all at this
point that i recently found a new job by
leveraging whatever i learned in this
course
the lesson we'll learn from the kovit
crisis is that there is a lot of things
left for the humanity to explore and
learn
the thirst for knowledge should never
stop
special thanks now to the medical
researchers whose knowledge and research
led us to the vaccines against kovit
just a continuous learning and all the
best to all of you
wish you good luck and all the health
and all the wealth thank you
thank you so much
it's really nice to hear that you have
landed your dream job and i think many
would
resonate to your thoughts today we would
have gone through the same journey and
thank you so much for sharing your
experience with us
you're welcome thank you okay
so we are going to give it a last try uh
namrata punam if you are able to
mute yourself you will be able to
check or else we will
speak the end
post can you check if for the one last
time
if um
there is some issue with
all right okay no issues let's move on
okay so now it's the time to celebrate
success it's uh time to honor each and
every one who has completed
their pg program with us uh post that we
will proceed to recognize all the
achievers in each category and celebrate
their success together
i would like to apologize uh earlier
because i may not pronounce all the
names right
so in
pg e
and post graduation program in devops we
have ali
anisha rohit tariq
william
jagannath
gajala jinsi
dipankar
shalini
and julie
congratulations everyone
we have mansi
sharik
divik
vikas
manuel
sonal
janakiram
congratulations all learners
we have sudarshan
mandana
mujwal
ravi
many congratulations learners
have joseph
tantalino
mahendra
and binu
many congratulations everyone
we have matthew ashilesh atkin
khalil
palio
ronald
shilpa ram
jeffrey
syed
urba
milos
eric
john
sherwin
sean
nicholas
orna
johnson mother
shabeed
hughes
rasheed
rahul
jason
many congratulations all learners
have vijay
stephen
thomas pawan
jonathan
lalith
ronald
nina
nila
himati
ebi
shafiollah
jay
and rona many congratulations everyone
for all the learners who have done their
post graduation program in devops many
congratulations
next we move on to cloud computing
so we start with usman
congratulations learners
we have roberta
dumont
vinit
sachin
resham
swaru
hirtha
palmsi
puja srinivas
many congratulations learners
we have rajesh
babita himanshu
nor
satya
suhi
deepa
and kaushik
many congratulations to all the
graduates today
we have abhishek
shimon
kalpesh
madhusudan
adam
abhishek
namrata
sriram
michael
constance
louis
many congratulations to all the learners
from close graduation program and cloud
computing many congratulations
next we move on to post graduation
program in full stack web development we
have kanika
raphael
pratyusha
many congratulations everyone this is
not very easy
very many congratulations to all our
graduates today
all right
now we move on to the interesting
segment so we know all of you here are
achievers since this is not an easy
journey and easy journey and it's not
something that can be easily achieved
but there are few learners who went a
step beyond and displayed their
competitive spirit so we have two sets
of awards here planned for the evening
first category of awards is the scholar
award
here we will felicitate the top two
performers in each category in terms of
completing their live classes their
projects and assessments in time
so first i would like to call out the
scholars for post graduate program in
devops
we have rasheed muhammad who has done
the course in 67 sorry 86 percent
and sahin wahid who has completed the
course at an 84.1 person
many congratulations scholars
uh rasheed and sayed if you're here
good it would be great to hear from you
hey rashid can you speak you can speak
now
can you hear me okay yes we can hear you
win
oh thank you uh yeah it's rashid
mohammed um
honestly like i've been in it for 25
years and
when i was looking around for for the um
for some organization or institute to
um to
attend some courses or to take my
career it was declining like the
technologies which i have learned like
over 25 years they were kind of like
getting obsolete now and
um i'm a subject matter expert in in a
bi area but taking my uh
keeping afloat uh and not drowning
into into this like i have to pick up
new technologies or even like in a
present where
uh those technologies i'm work on
uh they're moving to cloud or other
platforms which i had no clue and
my career was declining honestly
um
i found this
uh course and say advice a friend of
mine he helped me as well like i said
you know um this is a very good program
and i didn't know much about the caltech
or i simply learned at that time
so but i was looking for
uh two key thing one
um it would be something which fits my
schedule
uh
working and
full time and and studying it's not easy
with the family as well
um
so that was a
number one priority the second one was
the cost um can't really spend
a lot of money
uh we are not at the um
in in a life like me i'm not at the
estate where i can spend a lot of money
on it
uh the third thing was something
reputable
we saw caltech and i say you know what
um
going back to school after such many
years
it's difficult but i will do it
um sign up with the program
not knowing like how it's gonna be
turned out but
uh the when when the course was started
like
i found it like it's it's worth it it's
totally worth single penny which we
spend on it and the time
uh difficult definitely like a lot of my
colleague this area it was difficult on
on our family time spanning in here for
long months like for months definitely
was very difficult
but
um
also not only that like devils are just
apart when we sign up but in actual
uh what i found is the the the content
in the course they were
very appropriately picked
very
relevant to the industry
and
every time any lesson i learned any
class i attend
right away
i was relating it to my my job
i work for large multinational
organizations i'm working at a port
right now like
cutting edge technology but
anything what we heard in a class it was
relevant exactly to the job and the
the the good part was it was delivered
by experienced people that makes a big
difference
if i go with and just learn it with the
some instructor who teaches me
how a function or some functionality
works
it's not gonna give me what i i'm
looking for
the experience these teachers have
that makes a lot of difference
good content
a reputable organization and
excellent instructors made me
state throughout the the the
the program
um
learn it
and
definitely like like every single thing
which we learned it was relevant to the
the
the actual industry or work experience
i'm happy and actually not just a happy
i'm proud that i have
studied at simply learn i have studied
at caltech
um my affiliation with caltech now i
have uh with with the simply learn
definitely i'm proud of it and and i'm
happy
um really thank you thank you very much
for
setting up such a nice program
and delivering it uh really it it makes
my it gives a boost to my career
now
i have all those cutting edge
technologies which i needed
in my pulse
and with the experience with with the
good knowledge of it
thank you really i appreciate it
thank you so much rasheed it was just
lovely to hear you speak and uh thank
you so much for uh
inspiring many who are in the crowd and
uh congratulations again to be one of
our scholars
any congratulations
so moving on from cloud computing
we have
robota small
yes from cloud computing we have robota
usma who has
completed the goal uh completed the
course with
86.8 percent and we have uh mohammed
shabir who has completed the course with
87.4 percent
so if roberta and
ahmed if any one of you are available we
would like to
hear from you about your journey as well
whose can
if you are able to see them
yeah uh emma you can speak now
yes emma you can unmute yourself and you
can speak
university of southern california this
india system at me for last uh five or
six years
uh so in the mid of my career i have
looking for a course like cloud
computing to move forward my career
so
whenever i looking for that for the last
one year i'm not feel find any course
that really suits me like
working uh doing study and work together
and also
manage my family and all the stuff
so at the time i saw the caltech
and simply done so i feel i saw the
course catalog and all the programs and
i really impressed with the course
curriculum
because this is the only one program
that basically combined all the cloud
platforms like microsoft google and
amazon
so this is the first time i saw and i
did a research for it for this and this
curriculum looks best for me
so i am very interested and
involved myself in the course and
today i can say that i my decision was
correct and i really really feel
very excited
and
the course the journey was really
enjoyable because
after doing five days work the two days
is our weekend and at that time if the
course instructor and the course
curriculum was boring then that will be
very hard for us but
i am saying that the course curriculum
and the instructors and the way they
learned us that is really enjoyable i do
not feel
because
the class was four hours but
i do not feel such boring because not
feel any boringness on the classes
because the classes is very very well
structured like
design and then the
lab and all those things the all the
time
the we are doing online courses but we
are involved in the course through the
four hours
so
at uh and the course was like one year
and i really feel
uh and the course was enjoyable and the
structure the
learner and the learning experience the
instructors
and also the tas
and they are really helped me
so
i'm very actually good thank you
thank you so much
it was it was really lovely to hear you
speak and share your experience with us
we wish you all the very best and many
congratulations again for being one of
our scholars
thank you from uh full stack
development which is one of the toughest
scores which is double strikes we have
kanikaze with 65.4 percent and we have
rafael lopez with 65.3
many congratulations scholars if uh
tanika and rafael if you could share
your thoughts with us it will be really
nice to hear from you
yes
can you can you go ahead and speak
is gone on mute yeah
all right um if the rafale is available
yes kanika we have we can see you
unmuted
we are not able to hear you
okay
so host can you see if uh
yeah we can go ahead with rafael then
yes
hello raptor
unmuted
can unmute yourself
yes
yes hello everyone
well
[Music]
congratulations to everyone first of all
um pretty sure it wasn't an easy journey
for any of us um
thank you so much for the award i was i
wasn't really expecting it was a bit of
a surprise but i'm always happy to to to
you know get recognized and everything
um
but um
first things first i would like to um
but again congratulate everyone for for
this big
i'm pretty sure everyone is super
excited super proud and we always be
probably watching an easy journey but um
for me in particular
you know i would like to thank a few
people
for because it's not really an
achievement that is
it wasn't you know
it's a challenge achievement i feel uh
first
the unconditional support from my for my
family my my girlfriend you know
as other graduates have mentioned
already
the fact that you have to you know
sometimes put in some extra hours after
classes uh staying staying in
during the weekend staying up late at
night because something is not working
you have to finish projects assignments
you have to study um
so yeah i'm pretty sure that everyone
you know uh
okay that it's uh it's a big achievement
and and yeah
thanks thanks thank you to all for all
the support and
second um i'd like to thank um simpler
and caltech for putting together such an
amazing program um
as many have mentioned before
the the content
the all the resources that are available
online for us
it was all very very helpful then
structures the classes when i was um
looking for something you know so i was
looking for a
for for an online um
first that would give me
all you know that knowledge and needed
to to
yeah you know do a good job and and stay
relevant and as many people have
mentioned before
id is uh
it's always evolving there's always
something changing uh
you may you know in a week things change
so fast so when i look at the
simply learn um
offer and you know in partnership with
caltech all the tech stack everything
look looked amazing i was really excited
and i have to say it it live up to my my
expectations
and more than that
the instructors were always
super knowledgeable um
all the questions were answered
appropriately
in
and
all the support that we
we got from the staff throughout the
entire course was amazing
um
and also having a full-time job you know
having the flexibility to to study like
at your own pace and
classes during the weekend it was it was
all to be honest it was the perfect
combination it was it was exactly what i
what i was looking for
um
and
you know from assignments to homework to
to the capstone project which was
challenging it was fun to do but it was
challenging at the same time remember
many times
pulling my hair off no like it's not
working or something but
at the end of the day it's all good
experience that we that we get
and um
yeah thanks again deeply and and and
celtic for for giving us this amazing
opportunity and
once more congratulations to everyone
thank you
thank you rafael thank you for the kind
words uh it is really nice to hear from
you and
many congratulations to all the scholars
again
so not very easy as everyone has stated
and many congratulations to come out
with flying colors
uh thank you and next we move on to the
second set of awards which recognizes
the learners who are able to complete
the program end to end the shortest
duration
uh we call them the speedrunners
and for pg devops we have
rohit kumar who has completed the course
in 209 days and we have milo zizik who
has completed the course uh in 211 days
many congratulations speedrunners
and
if you roll with our milos if you could
share your thoughts with us it will be
really really helpful for us to
understand how you did it
how you felt about the course
hello
yeah am i audible
yes you are yes
yeah
yeah hi all good morning good evening
here hope everyone is doing well yeah so
i'm roid kumar i'm having a six year
experience as a devops engineer even
though i work
as a devops i was looking for some
a good course uh to
go forward in my career and learn some
new tools and
technology to enhance my knowledge
and by
doing so i came across this skel talk
program which was
organized or
by simply learn here so i opted for it
and
it was a great journey for me for this
past nine months uh it was uh difficult
as well as interesting for me but i got
to learn new things
new
thinking a new perception of lectures my
fellow teammates fellow
learners they all supported me and
everyone each of us in our batch was
very helpful we supported each other
very well uh trying to resolve our query
as well as
our faculty was very good
clearing out our doubts and everything
and
goes wise i think everybody in our
batch has done well we i thought if it
was the
group meeting or a gd type of thing we
would have completely congratulated each
one as all of our cells are done like
very well i don't know how i got
considered for this
but uh thank you kelter and
simply learn for
considering me for this
program as uh i've tried to
complete all the
tasks and assessment
uh thoroughly even though it was there
like only one you have to submit i tried
to go through all the assessment
to just enhance my
skill and solve few different uh
uh
[Music]
assessments what and scenarios wise
question what was like design for
assessment so that helped me a lot uh
giving me new ideas to implement in my
project also
and i'd like to like
thanks my parents and all colleagues
it can be difficult for me to
try
even
it was quite big
to
keep my family
until 11 p.m
so they have supported me well and
hope
that my site was a great journey with
everyone and i congratulate all my
fellow learners and all the learners
who have uh opted for simply learn and
can take different courses all the
courses
i think was well planned and all the
content was
well
architected based on the market wise
that the
learner perspective and
office
in
work culture wise everything was one
point everything helped one or the other
point
it has helped me in different tools
applying this all knowledge in my work
to enhance my growth and achievement in
office also
so yeah thanks thanks everyone missing
everyone like great health and
it's a holiday season starting in india
so happy
holidays and
happy festival everyone
and thank you all thank you thank you so
much great thank you so much thank you
happy festive for youtube
all right thank you so much and thank
you very much
so next we move on to uh postgraduate
program in cloud computing the speed
runners are
usman yakasai
with who has completed this course in
231 days and we have daniel chahil who
has completed the course in 277 days
many congratulations to both of you
who are the speedrunners for the cloud
computing course and uh
we can see if they are available to
share a few words
uh swan you can unmute yourself
um hello everyone
yes we can hear you
i'm extremely honored to receive such an
important recognition
of speedrunner award
it is indeed a privilege to study
amongst very bright minds
from our industry
each of whom is actually capable of
receiving this award
i would like to extend my sincere
gratitude to caltech and simply learn
who are the organizers of the cloud
computing program
it is not an exaggeration to say that
this program is very relevant to the
letters development taking place in iit
industry
providing professionals to build the
skills required for the work of tomorrow
the trainers structure intensity and the
delivery method
of the programs are simply exceptional
most importantly
the practical aspect of the course is
what provides students
with transferable skills to the industry
i have faced several challenges on my
way here
but each one of them has only
strengthened me to make me the person i
am today
a thorough professional who knows
exactly what he wants
someone who sets his eyes on a goal and
does not lose sight of it
unless it is achieved
winning this award would not have been
possible
without the inspiration i received from
my practice
and each one of my colleagues for whom i
have the deepest respect
and from whom i have drivers friends to
challenge myself and perform better at
each stage
i sincerely thank each one of you most
spiritually
my family
dr rick hechner
the best meter freebie
tutor and girlfriend
for helping me to reach a stage where
i can proudly hold up this award as a
mark of my achievement
after that
i want to share with you that i am
already microsoft azure certified
and looking forward to be aws satisfied
soon
on completing my program
it has boost my resume
are receiving at least 30 job alerts
in a day
on closing notes
all i want to tell each one of you
present here today
is that when you are faced with
difficulties you shall never
never never give up
even if you are convinced that it's all
over
it's not over unless you admit it to me
and a true example of this is me
sandra right here in front of you thank
you very much
thank you so much osman it was it was
really inspiring and many
congratulations to being a cloud
certified uh
earner and thank you all the very next
for the future as well
thank you thank you many congratulations
to being a speedrunner next we move on
to the post graduation program in full
stack development
right so here we have uh pratyusha
kocharoo who has finished the course in
a record time of 172 days and we have
sandeep jagaraju who has completed the
course in 237 days many congratulations
speedrunners pratyuksa and sandeep
if anyone is available we can have you
speak
for a few words
before we move on next
le protection
yes you are unmuted you can you can
speak
hi everyone can you hear me yes loud and
clear
okay great hi all uh thank you very much
for honoring me uh the speedrunner award
so i'm really very fortunate to find the
full stack web development postgraduate
program at caltech university ctme on
simply learn so um i was really
looking for uh upgrading my skills as a
software developer as a full stack
software developer so uh and also as a
new mom i was in a very much doubt
that whether i'll be i'll i really be
able to complete the course with
perfection within the time especially uh
the course online course during the
weekends with the baby
so uh with the extreme support of my
family and especially the simply learned
tutors and the team
helped me a lot uh to complete
the course within the time and received
a very good feedback from the tutors and
everyone else
and i got the opportunity to learn and
apply the whole new programming
framework which is java of in my current
job and then
i
i also
i'm also fortunate to build my
github repositories and github profile
in a professional way
uh the self learning content especially
is very
is well organized and really helped me
revisiting all the topics whenever
needed and the assessments
and the capstone projects are really
challenging and was able to complete
with the
help of my skills and my and and my
tutors especially all the tutors that i
have
come across
and
the skills that i learned are really
helping me to build as a real
professional
developer
that i want really wanted to be
so uh i really thank
and congratulate everyone
from the course
and uh and my tutors including tutors
and the especially the service uh
help help help team uh that helped me in
each and every uh question that i had
and thank you so much everyone from
simply learn caltech ctme and happy
learning take care and thank you for
this opportunity
thank you so much pratik shah it is
really inspiring to see you manny
congratulations uh
being speedrunners
all right apart from all the graduates
who have shared their experiences today
we would like to also thank every one of
you for uh actively reviewing us in
different social media platforms time
and now
we are super happy and excited to have
all your feedback put in different
social media platforms and appreciation
of our program and we have also received
feedbacks which has made us work harder
fix a lot of things and move forward to
giving you a better uh
so thank you everyone for uh spending
your valuable time and giving us the
right feedback
all right so now um we would like to
introduce you to the team behind the
scenes working relentlessly to make sure
that you have the best learning
experience
the idea behind this is to put a face to
the names you have heard and interacted
in the last one year
first i would like to introduce our
faculty team uh we would like to thank
each and every faculty uh for constantly
supporting us throughout the program and
they have been the major pillars of your
experience and we would like to take uh
call out each faculty and thank them on
your behalf
we have virender
wyatt
[ __ ]
ashitosh
praveen
sebastian
wahid
ayush
niraj
nagendra
thank you so much faculty for uh being
with us standing by our side and uh
giving the learners the experience that
they want
and
if we have any of our faculties
available today we could we could
have them speak few words
possible
if anyone is available
so this is ayushrati
i'm a cloud evangelist and have been a
faculty for the post graduation program
in cloud computing
so you all have been a part of this
wonderful program which has been a
blended learning program created by
simply learn and kel tech
i would want to wish you all
a very
many congratulations
all of our graduates a sincere
congratulations and best wishes for your
future career and educational as well as
the personal parts
your determination was truly awesome and
you all did it in the best possible way
uh during this pandemic i think you have
utilized the time in a very best
possible way and have gained the
knowledge
to be at par with the technology be it
devops or any of the cloud text
you are definitely reaching a major
milestone and achievement in your career
so here's wishing you a journey onwards
upwards and skywards thank you thank you
so much virendra for inspiring us and
being with us throughout this journey
and helping our learners out thank you
so much
right
if any
other faculty is available we can
available to speak that was ayo ayosh
oh that was sorry uh
sorry sorry irish nobody
so actually it's a
good privilege that i am on this
platform the first time to appreciate i
am joining this first time so yes uh
starting with just a small kind of thing
that uh simply known is not a platform
it's a good actually an opportunity for
the young learners simply learn just you
can break the word simply plus learning
it makes the learning as simple as
possible
so basically i joined this implant two
years two point five years back and till
now i've been like integral part of it
it's really amazing here actually we're
being a specialist trainer like i have
grown and took more than 70 plus batches
and trained more than 4000 students on
this platform too long and really in
this year i pushed my limits as well to
the learning inhabited domain and just
showcased my best in whatever training i
can do and dealing with the caltrak
student it was really a wonderful
experience for me the passion of
training just ignited me to always say
yes to every batch which i was getting
assigned with the motor to train the
student and to teach them in the most
simplest way so hats off actually and
wonderful congratulations to all the
people who have been shortlisted for
this program yeah thank you thank you
thank you so much virendra thank you so
much it was nice hearing from you again
thank you
thank you
all right do we have any other faculty
who would want to speak
today or
all right so we are moving on um we
would also like to thank our master
class instructors who are part of the
caltech family who have been
facilitating us with different
interesting topics um every month uh dr
john wetz
uh eugene ly matthew dartes
patrick alexander and dave todro
thank you so much uh instructors for
being with us throughout the journey and
helping the students
gain
the best of knowledge
uh moving to the core team at simply
learn
we have the learner success team
here is the team who's responsible for
the sessions and the tickets that you
post many would have interacted with
them directly or indirectly we have uh
aryan dipanshu nihal adarsh aishwarya
sanjana
nitin
this is the learner success team
next we have the fna team which is the
faculty and alignment team which is
responsible for
handpicking and getting us the best
trainers
the team consists of keshua simonth and
ayman
next we have the product team this team
is really the brains behind curating the
program and structuring it they have
been the bridge between simply learn and
celtic and they have been the drivers of
the program
we have sagar we have money and mayan
mithi
next we have the content team the team
that is responsible for all the content
and curriculum that we see in terms of
live virtual classes as well as the
self-learning videos we have paishaki
ravi
anjana
and siraj
i would like to take this moment
to thank and applaud for them for all
their effort and relentlessly working
towards making sure that the learners
have the best of experience that they
could thank you so much team
so this brings us to the end of our
first online convocation for post
graduation program with caltech ctme in
association with simplylearn we wish
each and every graduate all the very
best for their future and we believe
being aspirational is the first part of
being successful and you have come here
with an
aspiration and a dream and we are pretty
sure many of you will excel in different
streams of your career once again it's a
heartfelt gratitude from us
or choosing simply learn be your partner
to scale up thank you once again
everyone for making up uh making to this
event and we want to leave you with one
final thought you are now the
ambassadors of the caltech ctme simply
learn pg program as mark had previously
stated and people will start following
your footsteps and you will be the
guiding light to success for them so we
would request you to be active in our
communities post some interesting topics
for the future learners and also keep us
posted about your success stories as
well and do taggers and different social
media platforms so that we can celebrate
with your journey and you can also set
the path right for the future learners
as well
thank you so much for making up to this
event uh and making this event a
successful one and for one last time i
would request you to uh
there is a survey link below and i would
request you to give share your views uh
that has been pasted in the chat box
so it would be nice to hear from you
about you know the feedback of uh
the program the convocation everything
and uh thank you again thank you for
being here everyone uh good night good
day and good luck everyone thank you
thank you so much
patience take care
thank you mark thank you thank you
everyone congratulations to all the
learners thank you
great job guys
thank you thank you everyone thank you
everyone for being there thanks for
joining
all right thank you everyone